genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by Mint mobile signing
your life away to Big Wireless providers
it's kind of like being trapped on a
roller coaster from a hell sure looked
fun at first they probably threw it a
free phone but now you can't get off my
friend's mint mobile is just
$15 a month for a limited time Wireless
plans once again from mintmobile are
just $15 a month that's unlimited talk
text data for just $15 a month ditch big
Wireless with mt Mobile's limited time
deal and get premium wireless service
for 15 bucks a month to get your new
Unlimited Wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com genius5 that's
mintmobile.com
docomo domcom
genius5 genius brain listeners this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends if you haven't used better
help before now is the time to start I
love better help I love mental health
and whenever I need to talk to a
therapist better help is there for me my
friends do you ever find that as you're
trying to fall asleep your brain
suddenly won't stop talking I've been
there before and my thought starts to
race right before I go to sleep and it
just makes it super hard well guess what
sometimes I need to talk my Stu out and
therapy gives you a great place to do
that and you could do that with better
help my friends so to get a break from
your thoughts with betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com genius today to get 10%
off your first month that's betterhelp
hp.com genius you're the reason why
there's so many bad standups wrong all
right we have a mutual friend that we
know that every time he sees any Asian
person go up he goes you should try
stand up and they go up there and
they're not funny and they just bomb and
it's just terrible don't be that guy you
tell people when they're bad especially
if you care about them if you don't care
about them encourage
them dude do that same set for the next
5 years yeah keep doing it it's so funny
keep doing it in in 5 4 3 2 1 what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast we have two
very special people one person who's
actually special in the funniest way
possible we have Jason chenny here dude
two marbles knocking in that little
skull of his dude there's three marbles
right oh three Marbles and then we have
Patricio Riley what happened Patricio
Riley everybody yay highly requested
that these two come back and whenever
Pat is back in town we get the boys back
in town smoking cigars smoking cig my B
look at
this Jason already came 30 seconds into
the podcast I just excited so you came
back from New York how was
it tell us about it dude it was a great
ladies and gentlemen it was a great time
did you get any tags while you were out
there dude did you get any tags it was a
great time you know um this some
comedies what's some new faces huh uh
new faces old
faces what's your
problem sweat coming off of his
forehead are you on the road right now
yeah oh no I'm I'm off for like 3 weeks
I'm really excited because um I was
doing Naples Florida I was in I hav even
heard of Naples Florida it's actually a
beautiful beautiful place but um um yeah
I'm not going to say anything about the
club but uh it was okay and then uh went
to Miami for the first time oh you went
to Miami dude I never went to Miami
Miami dude Miami let me tell you
something if you're if you
like [__] dude yeah it's like when
you're there first of all I'm not
ashamed of how fat I am at all went to
Miami didn't take off my shirt yeah
couldn't do it you can't do it
everybody's buff yeah you two are fine
you on the other hand like the only
people who are fat in Miami are [__]
80-year-olds and then me that was it
dude everyone in Miami is fine as [__]
even like the TSA lady bombest Cuban
girl I've ever seen in my life I'm like
what the [__] I think I got cat you
down just come yeah my number one's
super fun lots of drinks lots of ladies
everybody's so goodl looking out there
dude you know what's crazy I think I
went to the wrong Miami because I didn't
see any maybe I didn't go to maybe I
didn't go to like the right places
because where were you where'd you go
were you on the beach I was oh no I
didn't go to the wait you didn't go to
beach in Connecticut or
something what the were you inami conut
I was in Miami Kansas City nice yeah
Miami Kansas City pretty cool too dude
pretty chill over there too what the
[__] you just see any Beach I I maybe I
went to the beach in Naples and maybe
it's because I didn't go to the the but
the food was really good though yeah
[__] the food [__] the food you didn't
see any of the the hot ladies I would
like to I would really want to see the
hot I would like I would like I would
like to see [__] please I would
really like to do that I'd like to see
some titties yeah dud half the ladies
out there and Men got AIDS for sure 100%
everybody's [__] out there wow it's
ridiculous that's so
nice I didn't f one time yeah Dam in
Miami Miami how long were you in Miami
for uh 2 days
you didn't do anything no I just I got
in and I did the spots and then um I I
went to lywood Windwood which is like
this mural thing I walked around and I
went to the museum thing it's just
boring stuff oh you didn't do anything
fun out there sounds like a horrible
what the [__] are you talking about I
don't have friends yeah but the way you
said it sounded like you were party you
went I went to myam what' you do I went
to
museum I read a boo
I uh had some
rice what the [__] why' you make it
sound like you were having a good time I
didn't s i I didn't sound like that yes
you did I I went to
myami and then what you
do I studied studied study I'm not in
school but I stud I stay in the hotel I
Hotel I took a shower dude Miami's
[__] fun as [__] yeah I didn't really
help even if you don't know anybody you
go to a bar out there you could chop it
up with anybody cuz nobody's really from
there cuz everybody's parted oh is that
yeah yeah I didn't really um you got a
huge fan base you could just like hit
one tweet hey yo somebody somebody show
me around Miami yeah right you don't
think somebody will show you around no I
us all the time like if I went if I did
a college
show and you know I mean like this is
like when I hit like what 26 27 28 it's
like I'm like 10 years older than all
these kids I would just go there I would
tweet out I'm going be in Miami let's
have fun but these kids can't drink they
can't come out and they're broke cuz
they're college students so I'm like
okay let me just go hang out and then
people would pick me up and I would just
go have a good time wow dope that's
sound
you could do that dumbass
yeah
yeah yeah dude it's fun out there yeah
next time I'm going to do it I'm going
to go to myumi again yeah don't do the
accent if you didn't have fun myumi yeah
I had a great time in Miami when was the
last time you went to Miami uh it's been
years um you've been you've been several
times I've been a few times that's I've
been a few times first time I went I was
with my parents so that wasn't that
crazy I was like 14 though but then I
went out a couple times I don't know
it's been years like eight years but it
was a a [__] good time and everyone
like everyone's fine like everyone the
Cuban lady at the restaurant like the
old lady is kind of bomb like I'm like
what the [__] like I love this
grandmother like I'll start a life with
you right now [__] like everyone is
like the food it feels like another
country too it doesn't feel like a
different country vibe to it kind of
like Hawaii feels like a different
country too like Miami has its own
little thing going on the water's super
[__] warm out there warm it's like
piss War dude piss ass baby so [__]
nice man yeah dude yeah you were inne I
was in Conneticut I was in Connecticut
Naples and uh the water is really I was
kind of mad because it was so hot so I
was like oh I'll just jump in the water
and it's like warm yeah wait what
happened with The Comedy Club oh
um you know what it's not the comic it's
just the demographic in Naples because
it's just like super rich people rich
people and like retired so they're like
older and then they will go to the thing
you got do political jokes about Biden
and Trump but yeah exactly they would
they love that like anything political
they love things they love yeah that
works yeah but the rest of the thing is
like what's he talking about like what
is this guy why is he talking about
[__] and
penis like we're going to church on what
do you what do you do when you're on
stage and then you lean in yeah
youan I did that in so I've been because
I move up to slow I've do shows in pass
now so it's like kind of like that the
other night I was on stage talking about
getting my ass licked and there was like
a group of ladies that were not in knew
it and I just started I just got more I
just started attacking him with graphic
vulgar details and the people on the
right liked it they hated it I was
having a great
time you guys having a good time I am
I'm having a blast but that's the thing
you have to have a great time cuz if
you're having a great time then they're
having a good time too if you're hating
the [__] that you're saying you're not
having a good time and they they're not
having a good time also it's like I'm
not going to let them make me have a bad
time because they don't like it like in
the beginning when I started it was all
about like just being afraid getting on
stage and then people pleasing like I
just want them to laugh I want them to
laugh but I'm starting to like get to
the point where I'm like if they if they
don't like me like [__] like you're not
going to make me feel bad so I'm going
to [__] with you to the max I'll blow
this [__] up you know what I mean
like I'll kill us all right now [__]
you're not having fun well suicide let's
go you don't think I'll [__] do this
[__] I'm Taliban [__] [__] you you just
got to go in a little bit I'm a comedian
I think that's like the sign of when you
see you know you get really comfortable
with what you're doing it's just like oh
there's there's a certain point of maybe
this set isn't funny and there's like oh
this is just not my crowd and you got to
kind of figure out which one's which
because I've seen certain like I saw
Bill Burr do same set twice right I
watched him once and I went with another
friend who wanted to go see him first
crowd was great second crowd wasn't that
great but same jokes and it was still
[__] funny so like you know sometimes
it's just like it's not your fault other
times it's your fault right and you have
a couple of
friends he can't he can't say out loud
but he's a because you're a nice guy
he's a nice guy I have a nice
guy I never did
that did no no hey good just bombed for
30 minutes a comedian who isn't a
comedian ever giving you advice about
your comedy set I know that's that's it
hurt a little bit bro some guys are so
unaware dude like I remember I won't say
the guy's name but there was a comic
this is years ago and like I was pretty
new too you know but we're in Westco at
some like bar some like Mexican bar and
this guy goes on stage and he's he's
like like Shakespearean and is like he's
like like just like super all out
bombing hard as [__] like but acting out
like he's like on Broadway like for 15
minutes straight you got respect the
commitment though he committed he
committed which I respect that damn that
was rough then he gets off stage he had
a little beanie on he took it off and he
looks at me and he like Rings it out
it's filled with sweat he Rings it out
he wet water looks at me and he's like
you see that that's work and then walked
away what the [__] bom for 50 made
everyone's time in there worse like
people are having a good time bad time
now so unaware that he bombed for 15
minutes straight like oh my God see that
that's work walked away he probably
knows he did bad and he has to cover it
up cuz there's people people like that
in auditions so I went for this audition
for the sitcom where I was supposed to
be a Mexican security
guard this is like early on in my career
no nobody knew where to place me right
cuz they were only casting like Asian
dudes in Asian dude roles right you're
either like the nerd The Geek The Tech
Guy whatever I don't fit any of that
[__] specifically because of the way
that I speak so like they would put me
every audition was either for a black
dude or a Mexican dude so I'm just like
okay cool we're we're going to this
audition we I sit down and you hear this
guy doing this audition and by the way
this is a single cam right meaning that
you however you speak like this is
basically how they kind of want it done
typically because multicam is theatrical
right you're performing when you see
sitcoms it's a little more whoa whatever
whatnot single cams you could pick up
all the new on so typically you'll act
you know a little more uh down to earth
right this guy goes in clearly he didn't
read the script he's like act wow then
all this other [__] I'm like everybody
stops we're like reading our life we
stop like what the [__] we're looking
out guy walks out kind of similar in
your fashion he goes nailed it you guys
can all go home and he just walks out I
was shocked so I was the next person up
I come in I go what the [__] was that
guys the whole [__] cast was laughing
dude they're like yeah [__] was that
they were like yeah sometimes you know
we you don't get to choose him I was
like if you guys pick him I'm going to
die right now I was just you know making
jokes they were laughing but I got a
call back but it didn't [__] pick you as
a Mexican security guard damn that's
[__] got two call backs for it though
so which is interesting that's pretty
yeah that's good but you never know
sometimes like they will pick like an
Asian or like a they just want to see
something right I mean at the end of the
day that show didn't get picked up
anyway so it doesn't [__] matter but
that's good you're a good actor you you
played a
Mexican hello my
friend this is the guy right here what's
his name name's
GMO time you talk hello what is that eat
AIG sign this man immediately wow that's
racist and it's
hilarious I'm at Home
Depot
seor hey good set dude good set good set
let me ask you something if if for real
zel right let's say I go up right I feel
like I killed it I'm feeling great about
myself you feel great I feel great about
myself but clearly it was a terrible set
right and I come up to you and I was
like I [__] killed that [__] what
would you say I will say good job damn
it Jason i j you're not supposed to do
that no no I won't tell you that was
hilarious that's funny but good job
because that could mean multiple things
that could mean that A for effort you I
mean that's how it
justify and it's true you are the worst
friend ever D you don't do that no no
but if you ask me was it funny I'll tell
you the truth yes you do you take me
aside and you go listen this is not for
you this is not for you at all no if I
really you go on stage right after I
just did a terrible set you come back
people are all laughing you kill it and
I go hey man you could have done better
yeah that's okay here's some notes thank
you yeah yeah what do you say I go thank
you Jason I go thank you your Jason I go
thank you for your nose because your
intention is a good intention yeah okay
you know what I'm saying okay okay I
don't give a [__] right this you're the
reason why there's so many bad standups
wrong all right we have a mutual friend
that we know that every time he sees any
Asian person go up he goes you should
try standup and they go up there and
they're not funny and they just bomb and
it's just terrible don't be that guy you
tell people when they're bad especially
if you care about them if you don't care
about them encourage
them dude do that same set for the next
five years yeah keep doing it it's so
funny keep doing it
[Laughter]
you could do it you can't do that you
have to tell people when they suck at
things so they can get better yeah I'll
give you a but who but sometimes I'm
like who the [__] [__] am I to say like
somebody's bad I think that there's a
clear Gap right like if it's somebody's
first year doing standup you've been
doing it for quite a while you do have
an ability to say like hey man what the
[__] was that you it's not saying that
they're not going to be a standup you
know what I'm saying but if they're just
starting out and they're doing terrible
let's say it's not stand up let's say
cooking right like if my wife well let's
not use my wife if I had a friend right
they cooked this dish it was [__]
amazing in their mind I ate it you ate
it and I go okay you at their house okay
give give me an example yeah you at
their house okay you you cook for me not
you cuz you're I know you're a terrible
cook I'm a great I cook good eggs all
right solid egg okay I boil
broccoli no I do good um French omelette
oh do you scramble you get the small
curds and you fold it over there's no
color on it just straight yellow
straight yellow and then it tastes like
there's cheese inside but there's no
cheese there's no
[Laughter]
cheese okay here we go let's do a
scenario I just had a feeling how you
guys know man we know you dude because
not much in there anyways so it's pretty
easy to get to know it's like reading a
book with the font like this big you
know what I'm saying pretty [__] easy
so you do a scenario I'm in the kitchen
oh no you made this meal you thing okay
I have salmon right and I and I plated
it right bring it out bring it out oh
thanks man dude this looks this looks
[__] amazing yeah I did I was hello
what's smell uh did you season this yeah
yeah yeah I put like a little bit of
salt a little bit of garlic powder hey
keyword a little bit this is UND
seasoned as [__] why the [__] would you
feed this to me are we friends I'm y
[__] with you but suck
though [__] with you but it
sucks see you get people you critique
them you make it funny okay yeah yeah
you know what I'm saying if it's someone
you care about for sure you got to say
but if you don't know them cuz I've been
there too where like if I don't know you
I'm I'm if I don't know you unless they
ask they ask if they ask I won't say
good I just I just like this if I they
did bad and like they they came off
stage I like
yeah but that's pretty much good job too
no it's just like it's just like you
went up it's more like you went up there
you went up this what this means [__]
happens that's what that means sh
happens [__] happens you went up there
right there [__] happens hurts dude yeah
when I get the [__] happens I go into
the bathroom I scream and I come back
out guys I'm good now some guys don't
get it though that I saw a guy bomb
recently hard bombed he was a headliner
he was do like 45 minutes he did 20
minutes he got off stage bombed hard
unprofessional as [__] after the show
was spitting game at all the women
trying to get their numbers all of them
saying like I was in this movie I was in
that movie and he was like dude you're a
psychopath cuz bombing hurts if I bomb I
want to [__] get in the car and drive
off the closest Bridge into the water
and die like just sit there and just
drown like that I don't have I would not
have the balls to go up to a woman that
was in the crowd that watched me bomb
and be like hey what's up baby like
what's what are you doing after this
yeah that's crazy that is bananas dude
that's a straight up psychopath psycho
you're a psycho you're literally
psychotic and but that's the thing like
we've we've seen now where I I think
pandemic basically made everybody think
that they're funny you know what I'm
saying a lot of people went on the thing
yeah they went everybody started doing
standup and I think you said it best
it's like stand up is the most
disrespected art ever dude like oh I
just got to go up there and just make
jokes it's like well technically yeah
but it doesn't mean that you're really
funny right and it happens to a lot of
people who have hype men around them
like where they just gas everything up
that they do like they'll they'll do
like hey man I want to sell these
[__] bracelets on Etsy you should do
it dud everybody would buy those and
then they [__] make these little
bracelets nobody buys it and they're
just like I don't get it I'm amazing
it's like no you're not and your friends
didn't tell you that those are stupid
bracelets you [__] idiot nobody wants
that [__] God damn it it's true see
that's what you have to do okay but hold
on but if they're happy doing the thing
and they're like oh man I'm a happy guy
no listen what the f oh man I'm happy
and I want him to be happy is the thing
do you know what I mean like yeah but
see when we're talking about people who
are trying to be in the business and
work on their craft and get better if
you're doing it just to be happy then
who cares then that is taking stage
taking stage time and and yeah yeah so
if a friend of mine like you let's say
you said you wanted to be a chef and you
cook me this [__] meal right yeah I got
be like yo did you hold a with your ass
okay but if I did my best but if I did
my best you're not going to yeah and I
also did my best not to trash you so
like there we're now we're even all
right if you have if your thing is that
you want to be a chef even if I'm not a
chef I have to be honest with you
because your goal is to make a career
out of this next thing you know okay if
it's a career yeah you open up a
restaurant nobody's in there yeah no no
I won't let you do that I won't let you
do that like if you do that no no
no no I never said all right I
understand a club I go up this is my set
hey guys so I'm from LA and I used to
work at 9 to-5 and you know in La we got
salvadorians hello my friend and I come
off stage and then Jason Goes Like This
he goes hey man inspirational
stuff that's what he did inspirational
stuff and look like I said this is not
from a judging point of view I just like
you know I don't know how many times
I've had somebody take me aside and say
dog you say this too much you know mean
you studed too much you're going too
fast through your set slow down and it's
usually from people who are who know
what they're doing you know I'm like I
am saying that [__] too fast yo take a
pause right there like that joke almost
hit but then you [__] did this too
much like you should have let them you
should have let it breathe a little bit
and then hit the punch line you went to
the punch line too fast you did another
one like [__] you're right I'll take
that but it's always from somebody who I
respect and they're good you I mean if
somebody who doesn't know what they're
talking about
and they they'll just like okay do this
joke hey I want you to go to the back of
me and then suck my dick from the back
like let's start with that you don't
know what you're talking about be quiet
you on the other hand I take a
notes I didn't say I didn't say I take a
notes that sounds like something you
would do you have to you have to be
critical of your friends because nobody
else will do it who else will yeah okay
okay yeah if if if if you're my friend
and you're really trying really hard
then I will tell you a thing if you ask
me yeah I I would do it but it's even if
they don't ask you you have to do it if
you're my friend and you're and you have
a goal and I see that you you know what
I mean then I would I would do it I
would I would uh so if Pat bombed if Pat
bombed he knows like but the thing is I
know him and how critical is he is to
himself so when he comes off I'll be
like good job
because you did you did your best you
know what I'm saying I will tell him a
good job because I know him dude that's
actually the worst thing you could say
to me after I think that's the worst
thing someone can say to you after a
bomb is going good job it's just like
okay what do you want me to say to you
[__] what do you want me to say to you
oh yeah good job would be the worst
thing good job is the worst thing but I
mean it actually if you bombed I would
probably also say good job just cuz it
would be funny to me to say that to
you you're great out there dude hey
inspirational stuff dude inspirational
stuff okay regardless of what what you
say I'm hurting I would yeah what would
you like me to do I would I would I mean
it's such a [__] feeling I would just
want you to you don't you just there's
no best way to do
it what mean z you [__] kill yourself
you go Z no you got to do
you what happened I would be like what
what happened you know I I would want
you to
say if you had an opinion or like if you
had notes that would be better than good
don't say good job oh good job is like
the I feel like it's so insulting if you
bomb and you get off stage someone says
good job I'm like okay not [__] hate
you you know that was not a good job
what I what a buddy of mine used to say
to me when I did bad he would say this
how'd you feel and I'm like yeah you
know how I feel [__] yeah how you feel
is the worst how you feel I don't I hate
how you feel how you feel is the I said
seven jokes and nobody laughed how you
feel how you feel is the worst thing
yeah cuz you already know what yeah you
it was terrible how he feel was the
[__] you never would say that when
people make excuses for the crowd ah
they're just like they're not on board
you know they're just like they're a
little weird like dude I was there [__]
off D I'm also in the crowd I did not
laugh I'm so sorry I told the story on
the podcast before when I first came to
La like this was my first time doing
standup in a long time because we were
doing YouTube and I was so [__]
nervous like my stomach was turning the
set wasn't that great but you know like
ice house pasaden and when the crowd is
good they just they're really nice to
you which I appreciate right so I got a
good few good laughs I'm like that
wasn't so bad even though I almost threw
up on stage it's been so long and you
know I'm doing standup in a new city
right cuz I was only doing San Francisco
Sacramento and then wherever you know me
and my buddies would go but I never did
like LA but South Pasadena Ice House was
just like a good introduction right just
a lot easier uh in terms of the crowd
they're just they're just there for a
good time dude that's a magical
room my lovely genius brain listeners
this podcast is brought to you by
mintmobile signing your life away to a
big wireless provider is like kind of
being on trapped on a roller coaster
it's super scary but let me tell you
something what that's a roller coaster
from hell cuz it looked fun at first
they probably threw in a free phone but
now you can't get off month after month
of insane bills and unexpected Thrills
like overages and surprise fees if that
sounds like your current big Wireless
plan it's time to get off the ride with
mint mobile for a limited time Wireless
plans from mint mobile are just $15 a
month that's unlimited talk Tex and data
for just $15 a month listen my friends
it is awesome everything is increasing
in price and to have something like
mmobile that's reliable where you know
it's just going to be $15 a month
unlimited is super amazing because it
helps me feel secure uh say bye-bye to
your big Wireless plans jawdropping
monthly bills and unexpected over all
plans come with unlimited talk and text
highspeed Data delivered on your nation
on the nation's largest 5G Network to
get your new Unlimited Wireless P for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
ship to your door for free go to
mobile.com genius5 that's mintmobile.com
genius5 cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mobile.com
genius5 my lovely genius brain listeners
no matter why you shave Harry's has you
covered for the best shave of your life
at a price you'll love from their
legendary high quality rers to skin
products like exfoliating face wash and
Hydrating Lotion Harry's gives you a
premium shave without the premium price
tag that is the biggest reason why I use
only Harry's Shavers all right I have a
bunch of Harry Shavers locked and loaded
and ready and whenever I don't need I
pop off that shaver I put on a new one I
actually like them because of their
design it's very minimalistic and very
simple and sharp as heck and let me tell
you something guys freaking amazing a
smooth shave shouldn't be rough on your
wallet the starter set is a $13 value
for just $3 at harry.com genius it
includes a five blade shman engineered
razor weighted handle foaming shave
foaming shave gel and a travel cover
scheduled delivery for refills as low as
$2 half of what you pay for other blades
my friends so get your best shave ever
this summer with Harry's razors and skin
care products get a $13 starter set for
just $3 at harry's.com
genius that's harris.com genius for a $3
Starter
Set genius spray and listeners this
podcast is brought to you by better help
my friends if you haven't tried mental
health things then you should try it
with better help I've been using better
help for quite a while now they've been
a sponsor on this podcast for a very
long time obviously have a lot of things
to work on myself personally and my
therapists is there to help me out I
have you know I don't know life gets
tough life gets rough and sometimes you
have a lot of trouble sleeping and
you'll actually find out that it's just
you just not being able to get your mind
to shut off and when I talk to my
therapist I feel so much better better I
feel so much better I feel better I feel
light and I feel like I could just
conquer the world and my friends if
that's you then try better Help Therapy
it's pretty amazing if you're thinking
of starting therapy give better help a
try is entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge make
your brain your friend with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com genius today to get
10% off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
genius it is they're there for a good
time and then you know obviously too if
it's not that funny you could tell
they'll giggle a little bit but you
could tell it wasn't that funny so I go
there I do a okay set and there was a
dude there that basically saw that I was
uh they kind of they put me as like uh
well I wasn't the headline but I was
just a right before because I had a
YouTube following that's so I brought a
small crowd in where there the guy comes
up he goes oh man so you've been doing a
so you do stand up huh I'm like yeah man
and I'm like oh yeah he goes yeah well
I've been doing it for like three years
so if you if you need any advices let me
know cuz I saw you're on YouTube and I'm
like okay you know that [__] you little
B comes out a little bit but at that
point I've been doing since I was 16 and
I was 25 i' doing it way longer than you
so I'm like oh this guy must be [__]
funny let's see goes up on stage i' till
this day I've never seen somebody bomb
that bad oh no way that's the an example
of somebody who's completely not aware
of anything nobody has told him he's bad
he comes off stage and I was just like
good set right you know I just kept
making fun of him CU I was so I was kind
of like confrontational when I was
younger I just just wouldn't let I just
wouldn't let it go you know what I mean
I just kept going in on him because I
don't think anybody good would ever be
like if you need if you need help I got
you before he even got to see me go up
you know what I'm
so disrespectful I thought that [__] was
so mean but at the time you know
whenever uh it's not like that anymore
but traditional media people standing
people hated YouTube people like they
just didn't like us cuz they thought
that they have worked so hard on their
craft for so long they've never been
able to work up a following for us we do
a couple of funny videos and suddenly we
can book out shows and so they would
piss them off whenever we see it and
like whenever I would try to like do
shows they would specifically put my
name as YouTuber right next to it they
wouldn't put me com wow yeah and that
dude you know what's crazy I was just
seeing you talk right now and I just
have Epiphany right now what why are you
say it like that dud that's the first
time you ever use that word but continue
this is the 32nd time because I saw Bad
Boys um how many 10 years ago and uh Mar
Martin Lauren said I I just had an
epiphany and I had to Google it okay and
I learned it of course you IDI and I
used it like 32 times 32 since like
10 what does epiphany mean you know what
it means
man like a idea just like a yeah you
don't need to
explain if you guys are old enough out
there if you had internet before there
was like decent DSL internet or some
[__] they used to make the
sound that's what that was right that's
how IDE working Jason head they pop in
he's
like dude I just had an to just hear you
talk right now I think you're um really
successful and I think you're losing
your [__] what do you
mean what do you
mean I don't think you're a normal
person what are you talking
about how am about not a normal person I
think I think um because you in the you
do the YouTubes uhhuh and you do the
business things and you you grow the
tomatoes and I think you've lost touch
with Humanity Humanity what are you say
what are you
talking I don't think you know I don't
think you know how normal we will live
life no yes I do why' your voice go on
so high listen
Humanity
listen I think you're doing a great
you're don't say you're normal bro I you
plant potatoes without potato you PL
tomato tomatoes for mon straight in a
[__] Aima hat and then you got how to
do a
podcast I look at your face and how you
talk I'm like this guy is living in the
moon for a long time can I okay can I
just say second he walks in and he just
puts on a stack of $100 bill for
slippers and he Glides to his
bedroom and has a good time with his
wife and his his wife is like what are
you doing tomorrow I don't know
tomato I want to do jiujitsu a little
bit hit some stuff hey let me tell you
something right don't you you know why
this is like so offensive to me is that
this half card is judging me right now
that's hilarious yesterday on a text
thread right he sends me a video us a
video of a lady chewing on a monkey
skull yeah like monkey skull like I'm
talking about a skull of a primate and
she's literally chewing the meat off of
it he goes goes hey guys look kind of
good huh you judging me okay let me tell
you something I need they need context
okay what is the context I want to tell
you because it's it's a tribe they they
eat the the the food they eat the food
it was a Hut it was a village of people
they weren't in the video but she was
having lunch by herself because she was
on
break she was on she was taking a break
was taking a lunch break Rob does a
context help you at all hold on let me I
haven't known what's going on for the
past 25 minutes okay there it is yeah
there you go okay hold on but it was
food for the village and it looks like
really organic food because it's like
the monkey yeah I don't know I'm not
wasn't sure if was a monkey it was a
monkey okay and but she was eating it
but it was uh food for that Village and
it just seems like natural and organic
and and just because you say natural and
organic it doesn't mean it's FDA
approved FDA
approv Korean culture there's a thing
called chbar and it's Pig um feet feet
and um and this is just instead of the
feet is
face and you could dip it in sauce and
you eat it are we in an interrogation
room am I a cop right now it sounds like
I'm shaking you down for information
right now and you made no sense you
wasted 5 minutes of my life right now
explaining nothing but does it not look
good a little bit Jason what happened to
you okay the context okay you know okay
so there's a tree in front of my house
right you know in trees when they fall
down sometimes they have fruit it's very
delicious and very organic but when you
know the tree hits you know and grass
hey you you hear grass that's why I'm
late that's what you just did me B the
big punch line instead of feet it's face
though like like you were like this is
going to get him right here instead of
feet it's face like what hey man he man
hey man it's like Caba Caba see it's
like monkey cabesa stff I said dude
inspirational stuff dude that I don't
know what you just said but I like have
you not heard of Fufu do you know what I
mean the food I know what Fufu is had
before say is yam you have I really
wanted it but that's what I'm saying but
sometimes they will make that in their
Villages right and the fuu they use they
will dip it into the juices in in like a
concaved rock place he sent me this
video of these dudes and listen this is
not me being culturally insensitive or
whatever whatnot right because you see a
bunch of people in the comments who are
from that area that are like why the
[__] are they eating it like that like
it's they they have Fufu and they they
cooked or stewed down a meat in a dirt
hole and they were just dir hole wrong
it was a what was it it was a rock hole
dirt is
manable bro Jason is what yo this guy
using new words today today before he
came in he goes I got to sound smart and
I'm making sure that I use these
words ear today these ideas are
erroneous is what that mean Anonymous
but
but but valuable he literally sent me us
a video of somebody eating this skull
meat and it was the most [__] gnarly
thing I've ever seen even if right we
understand well David it comes from an I
know but you're seeing a [__]
primates are so close to us genetically
it's unreal and like I said you should
be more freaked out because it's more
close to you than everybody else you
[__] you [__] C man dude the Home
Depot bucket one was nasty too where
that lady had that prickly pear or
whatever the [__] it was and the water
was green she was making that that was
actually the that is the stomach
contents of a cow it's the bile it's the
bile that comes out of it that green
juice is bile that's what I'm saying but
the bio bro but let me tell you
something was also smothered in [__] on
the outside did you see that it's not
[__] though it's it's so uh it's the the
it's I think it's a sheep's stomach they
open it but sheep eat grass and grass is
good dude what dude I'm gonna [__]
fist fight you right
now I'm going to [__] fist fight you
right now
PB where just explains nutrition go okay
but she peeled the
okay but it's only grass the the Sheep
is not eating like you know um protein
bars the Sheep is eating organic grass
so then the just cuz you say you sound
you know what what's triggering me right
now you sound just like my [__] dad
my dad every time every time right let
me just tell you this [__] this man
doesn't listen to me at all okay he he
you're just like my dad when my dad
learns an English word he doesn't stop
using it and [__] pisses me off the
last year he learned the word organic
he's practicing he has used that word
for everything cuz my mom Gardens right
so he's I visited Sacramento a week ago
right and he goes hey this are organic
I'm like okay I get it he goes yeah bud
organic I'm like got it Dad The Grapes
were organic you grew it he goes you
have a grape
organic and I look and you just hear my
mom in a distance like in Korean shut
the [__] up you [__] say organic oh
time nobody cares we know it's organic I
grew it I know he go why it's organic
and they're yelling at each other what's
the r with the organic I can't say
organic no nobody cares about your
stupid organic Graves yeah and they goes
fine I'll stop saying it 5 minutes later
hey you have organic grave yeah yeah
dude dog hell yeah pissed off this is
what he does I leave the Sacramento I
should have to taken a photo of this
first of all you know Asian parents have
this idea of like
if they don't see you in a long time you
give you a bunch of food right even
though we can't fit it in our fridge by
the time we eat it it's going to spoil
I'm like hey don't give us this much we
can't eat it all she goes cool we'll
just give you some fruits so she's
picking these grapes I see her yes they
bought the organic grape she comes back
out I'm I'm driving home I don't realize
what I took I look at this box there's I
was like wait there's three boxes here
what is this it's all the grapes from
all the grape finds in the house she
sent me home with 10 lbs of grapes
godamn and then what does it say on top
of the [__] Bo organic grape I called
my
dad why do you need to write organic
grapes he's like because you have to
know I know I'm not selling this at a
farmer's market we I don't need to know
it's organic he goes but hey
organic he has been saying that word so
much I was like why is this guy saying
organic pissing me off right now yeah
organic is a good word though organic is
a good word and also when you give it to
your friends the grave
they know is organic organic that's what
I'm saying they do cuz it on the box dud
we should have a segment where Jason
just introduces a new word that he
learned for the week and just he just
defines it and uses it in a sentence
Epiphany this mic is stupendous yeah
yeah yeah organic organic you know what
I mean what was that but just because
something's organic doesn't mean it's
delicious okay organic grass from a
sheep's intestines is what you were
talking about yes but they take it off
so the so so the [__] comes out of their
ass is organic are you going to eat that
too wrong no wrong wrong but but the
thing is is when you take it off now the
stomach is very clean cuz she washes
[Music]
it and you and you cuz it friction cuz
friction it takes the dirt off of it
that's true that's true that's a good
point yeah yeah that's a good point
thank you brother friction cuz sometimes
they don't do the friction when they
wash stuff yeah you mean they go so are
you telling me you would drink that
grass juice I would want Drass eat the
stomach I I want to wash them myself and
then cuz I don't trust them I would do a
little extra two time two extra pumps
dude so the it's bile juice yeah you
don't want to eat the bile juice she she
drank it so I don't know if she drank
she was drinking it the only reason why
I like bile is because I saw I think
like it was like a village in Cambodia
or Thailand that they were taking the
bile and they were do they make a sauce
out of it with chilies and fish sauce
God and then Andrew zimon ate it and he
was like oh damn was so bitter right he
was like he didn't and Andrew zimon
literally eats ass every day you know
what I mean and so he ate that he's like
I can't do this this is bad that's
terrible Andrew Zimmer dude like no way
man bile dude and there's that guy who
that dude in India that sharpened his
toenail and then he was cutting the
chicken with it bro I saw that one that
one was crazy and then you got hungry
huh
you dude that's organic toenail that's
organic my favorite one is a Dude that
[__] has no arm and that he just
takes the bread and he needs the bread
in his armpit oh oh yeah bro that was
insane he got no arm and then he
squeezes it with the with the armpit
just to make it like more flat in his
inside his armpit arm [__] disgusting
dude that one's gnarly you know what's
tripping me out man like nowadays with
food everything is so expensive like I I
just went back and there's a couple of
places that I go to you know around
Highland Park and there's a couple
places I wanted to try and today it was
a bagel joint is delicious but I just
looked at their price and this is not
their fault everything all everything
just rose up in prices because of uh Co
I look back everything on their menu
jumped up five bucks five that's insane
dude a full Bagel sandwich there cost
$17 God damn plus tax and tip that's 21
bucks oh my for a bagel sandwich that's
insane how the [__] that's ridiculous
man yeah I like when I after I bought it
ate it and I was like I could have made
this at home yeah I literally could have
made this at home for like two bucks
a150 dude that plus gas dude how the
[__] do you survive gas is like $8 bro
I'm I'm [__] burning my uh Forerunner
in a accidental car accident so I can
get a car that actually it's not killing
me $140 to fill my car right now and I
fill up once a week damn ridiculous man
it's worth more than my car you drive a
lot I drive a lot yeah cuz I have to go
back and forth you know because business
stuff you know business these Tomatoes
don't [__] tomato themselves that's
true business Irvine jie that was J
opened up you know what was you did the
yeah up kissed a bunch of random women
and
men there was a when we were in JY
Irvine it's interesting cuz we're doing
this meet and greet and you know I don't
really post as much as I used to I don't
really make like YouTube content anymore
we do the podcast and stuff but that's a
very Niche following so you don't really
when I do these meet and greets I'm
always like it would be the saddest
thing if I did this meet and greet and
five people showed up like I would be so
[__] sad not because like I'm sad
nobody knows me is because the audacity
that I decided to do a me greet nobody
knows me it's like who the [__] maybe
I'm the clueless one right we go there
there was like [__] 400 and something
people there damn it was nuts so when we
were there I was like oh [__] like there
are people here blew my [__] mind and
like some of these people have been
watching us for like 10 11 12 years and
they still watch us now is [__] crazy
so you get to see all these people
they're super nice super sweet man uh
there was one person that was there that
was a little little handsy I did not
appreciate it what he do it was a man uh
it was a girl but then it was like
there's people here you have bubble in
your hey there's people here hey there's
people here do it take me take
me so we were taking a photo right and
this girl uh [__] puts her hand in my
back pocket like we're taking a photo
but I thought it was Bart cuz Bart [__]
around a lot so I stopped I looked at
Bart I
go and I see his hands I look at his
hands the wait his hands on my shoulder
was like who's squeezing my ass yeah
yeah and then I like like a little old
man [__] girl like a little old man
like old man and he's breathing in my
ass my [__] stach
fu stop inflating
me and I thought I was like who the [__]
is grabbing my ass and I thought I was
like kind of shook I I just got sexually
harassed yeah that's a little odd and
then afterwards like you can't really
compute what's happening cuz I don't get
sexually harassed I'm not really what
you call sex appeal she's not that cute
if she was then you wouldn't say that oh
first of all first of all he wouldn't
bring this up first of all she was so
[__] average and you have no
idea how [__] amazing that was I love
average women average women are the best
they have the best personalities and
they're and they're good to look at
right they don't have to
the small percentage of women out there
that are extremely hot it's very small
all right and guess what you hot [__]
have nothing to offer me okay I can you
could walk by me I'll masturbate to you
all day that's all I need you for all
right is that weird is that is that
weird is that weird is that weird guys
is that weird it's not weird it's normal
dude no but like I that was like one of
the first times I probably gotten like
sexually harassed like that you got
groped you got grabbed after she left
like went to the bathroom cried no I'm
kidding i' be honest with you a little
bit I ain't going to lie as a guy
because I don't feel any imminent danger
yeah I was like I still got it yeah your
boy still got it you know what I'm
saying it don't matter if you was 60
your boy still got it yeah a little grab
you know what I'm saying you could come
inside of no babies yeah wait let let me
ask you something little mood booster
baby hell yeah is this is like a video
that I saw because you said that
sexually harass thing I was watching
this video oh oh it was on Love is Blind
so sorry if it's a spoiler but this guy
he was saying how like when he was
younger like when he was like 18 or
something 19 uh a woman like was drunk
and she um forced him to have sex and he
said no wait how did she force him to
have sex like he's she he was saying
that she was like oh like come on and
puts him into the bedroom like kind of
grabbed and he was in bed and he was
like no I don't you know but his dick
got hard he his dick got hard and then
he he addressed that he's like my dick
got hard but you know people he said
that he's like my dick got hard and
that's this is where people was like
yeah but your dick was hard and you know
he was like yeah but still I didn't want
it it's just that in the how did you
turn a funny story into something so
depressing dud thank you for ruining the
[__] mood I was just making jokes and
now I got serious and now I'm going to
have to call the police on her wait so
what happened what that's the that's my
question is that cuz you said you got
sexual harass sexual harassment right
like it goes both ways I think like the
difference is that especially how girls
explained is like the difference between
like when it happens to a guy versus a
girl is that a girl always feels
imminent danger like some shit's going
[__] happen if a guy's bigger and
stronger right unless the girls like
lizo like you you could [__] stop
them you know what I'm saying Lio would
be a problem Lio strong as [__] too and
she's
flexible stomach like and you're not
really getting through it's like Majin
Buu dude I and she's
like I do not endorse these comments
lizo I love you you do look like Majin
Buu like Liz will just do a cartwheel on
you and end your life you're done so
it's pretty much it yeah but but like
that's like how it's explained it's like
yeah when a girl like gets like an
unwanted butt touch she feels like a
sense of danger like this guy can a
sexually assault me like for me as a
male when a girl grabs my butt I grab
her hand and be like don't [__] touch
me like that the [__] are you doing the
weird thing is I didn't even get to do
that and be like see it happens to men
to cuz I thought I kept thinking it was
Bart you know what I mean and by the
time she left I was like wait she
[__] harassed me would you have you
have no because it felt great even if
you would have everyone would have been
like who who cares yeah who cares well
cuz I'm 6' one you know me the girl's
like what 5 foot three it's like the
most I could do is like girl you can't
do that like you know what I'm saying or
just like hey stop or I just like hey I
don't really appreciate it or I'd be
like hey I really needed that today
thank you so much you know my wife says
I'm not attractive but you clearly are
attractive to me that's the thing is
even if you get fed as a dude it's kind
of chill like I I work one time I was I
used to work behind the bar and I was
like doing dishes or whatever I was
cleaning glasswar and this one of my
other co-workers this girl who you know
she was cool but she was like you know
not the most attractive lady but she was
chill comes up from behind me and just
grabs under my P just grabs my dick and
balls and goes what's this about what's
this about and like just I was like what
the [__] I was like holy [__] and then
she just walked it was like tornado they
came from so how' you feel after you
came bro yeah I like oh thanks so much
dude she came in and just jostled my
balls and then walked I didn't even have
a moment to be like yo what who is this
and walked out and then I was just kind
of laughed I was like that was actually
kind of funny and then that was it that
was the exent of my I'm saying it's like
as as a guy we just don't feel the
danger you know what I'm saying like you
do that to a girl that even that would
make me mad but for some reason as a guy
I don't know what's wired in her [__]
heads kind of funny it's like when a
girl does that to us we just
still got
it I went went home and I told Mary I
was like Hey women find your man
attractive she go what happened I was
like well I was in line this [__]
girl grabbed my butt and she was like
well did she do it to any other people
I'm like why you do that why you do that
baby why you do that she go who she like
well I'm just asking did she like harass
anybody else and I'm like yeah there was
somebody else she goes so you're not
that special I'm like okay well you
ruined it I don't care anymore I don't
[__] care anymore dude damn dud it
doesn't matter I thought I had it but
clearly whatever
all right so what she's average so what
she's a little creepy all right she
still wanted me yeah right and that's
what matters and that's what matters
kids remember if you're a man out there
and you call a police on a girl for
sexually harassing you you're a [__]
yeah yeah yeah not that guy though so he
felt really sad that guy could have
gotten out of there dude well why why
not that guy I was just curious because
I'm like I would think that he would be
phys maybe he's he's really young too
was it the older woman 18 was it an
older woman though that's a good
question actually I don't know cuz if it
was an older woman then it's weird for
him right cuz he doesn't know like when
people have like that age Gap or
sometimes when they're in a position
Authority you just kind of like do I
really see do something here with this
especially as a young guy you know what
I mean also there's like pressure as a
young man where you feel like oh if you
do say something are you a [__] so
maybe he just didn't want it and as a
young person you know your dick gets
hard over everything okay what if you're
30 30 yeah and a woman decid to do a
thing am I single you're single oh I'm
single I'm 30 right and this girl do I
find her attractive she's okay she's
average and she's like let's [__] yeah
and and then she grabs me by my wrist
grab you by your wrist and then throw
you and then suddenly I take off my
clothes yeah yeah oh no and then what
else oh oh no oh oh No and then she
licks her nipple a little bit okay then
we're [__] at that point yeah yeah
100% dude there are times that listen
you know back in the day yeah there are
some people who I didn't want to hook up
with but it was just the right place at
the right time and you just do it and we
just do it you just do it it's like
you're being nice yeah and I'm being a
very good person but at the same time
she's being a very good person you know
what I mean so we just kind of like oh
it happened nothing of it yeah it is
what it is just move on like if I see a
18-year-old and like let's say a 40y old
woman who was like a mentor start doing
yeah that's [__] up cuz that kid he's
18 Ian he's an adult but still super
young kind of doesn't know what to do or
say in that situation right so I
definitely feel bad for me like I'm 35
years old I don't know who grabbed or
touched me and nothing's happening then
it's just more like oh you think I'm hot
do you and like she came up to me she
was like yeah [__] suck my [__] yeah
you know then I was like dude do you
read my mind or
what like whoa dude hey it is what it is
well going to end this podcast on that
no guys suuck my [__] dude all right
hell um you guys can find Pat at
Patricio Ry that's me you know I've been
saying patrick. T.Y for the longest time
you haven't corrected me it's CU it's I
like it it sounds good it was the old
one it's patrio be polite too man just I
like when he says it Patrick Doo Riley
I'm like oh sick butore Riley and it's
Jason chenny c h NE y c h n y sorry no
no there's a e y at no no there no
there's a ey and there's an
ampersand
Ampersand [__] I don't know what AM is
either yeah what's an ERS
end is
a sandpaper Middle Eastern Car okay that
goes in the desert oh nice wow ERS Sands
Amber sand it's also a coffee store in
Canada oh that is actually true Amber
sand yes it's also the and symbol yes oh
that's what it is yep know wait which
one is it is it the one that's looks
like an or the one that's like like an
eight with the three with the little the
top and the bottom line you know what
I'm talking about that that's a gay
eight that's a gay eight
sir that's a gay eight that's it's the
the swirly thing right the and right
there's two and symbol it's the one that
looks like an eight I'm not sure what
the one that looks like I knew why is
there so many an like just pick one you
know cuz the American the English
language is so [__] stupid dude it's
literally a conglomeration of like four
different language smashed into one it's
one of the most difficult languages to
learn yeah it's so dumb dude like Asian
languages are so easy because you could
just say whatever for a single object
for American is like American English is
like a thousand words for I don't
understand why so complicated wrong but
what all right yeah because Mandarin is
a whole character thing that you have to
learn to write the character thing yeah
but that's the writing part
wrong correct me then you [__] ching
chong
[__] um remember the goat
stach yes
hello what the [__] is going on can I
tell crazy can I tell you something go
ahead yesterday hell yeah dude I took a
uh hydroxy scine what's that okay now
you're just making [__] up it's hydroxy
cut continue wrong no no no hydroxy okay
what is it for it's for autism relax yes
it's for autism and it's for sleeping
and I took one and now I feel I feel
nice you know what's better than that
what weed yeah but I get too paranoid
with THC CBD would be nice oh you get
paranoid with weed yeah I get but I
don't used to I never did until uh like
the past like six years I get so
paranoid that sh never makes me paranoid
it it knocks me out oh you get paranoid
huh parid my brother too like when he
takes it he just like he's like freaking
out I literally think I'm going to get
arrested for I don't know why but I
think like I start feeling like like I
started thinking of like past [__] and
I'm like oh [__] I think like stuff that
yeah yeah or just like I just feel
shitty dude like I just feel really for
some reason I'm always on a boat in an
ocean that's awesome that's so nice like
when it gets hard I'm always in the
ocean on a boat by myself in a in in the
nighttime what I'm not even lying and
this is when it gets bad for you when it
gets bad and I'm just floating and I'm
just in the ocean and that's what I see
what yeah so when I'm trying to fall
asleep I'm just always in a mo in the
ocean swaying that's so nice and then I
look up and there's like stars stars and
[__] s nice yeah I don't know what type
of weed I'd be taken but like it's like
that moment right before I'm about to
fall asleep I I feel like I'm in the
middle of the ocean wow that's such a
good experience and then it knocks me
the [__] out and I wake up and I'm good
to go that's beautiful dude I smoke a
little weed I I question if my wife
still likes me I really do I listen you
don't need to worry about that she hates
I question if she likes me too I
question the same thing about the exact
same thing Wonder wife still likes damn
we both get paranoid man for some reason
when I buy I wonder that about your wife
too oh my God we have so much in
common well guys genius spr every Sunday
is at 12m uh you could catch them their
shows right here follow them make sure
is it's Jason J a y s o n wrong Amber
Sams Amer Sams Amer Dam hey somebody
call the
a [__] Jason c h n y and
Patricio Ry check them out for their uh
standup shows go ahead and see them
there laugh your ass off and laugh that
coochie off we will see you all next
time
peace